hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand-new 2020 16 inch MacBook Pro with
the new Radeon 5600 M graphics card that
is a very spendy upgrade today we're
going to figure out if that new graphics
card is worth it in a variety of tasks
now as I open up this MacBook Pro let me
tell you about our new Macs tech merch
we have these new premium hoodies that
are ultra soft ultra comfortable if you
guys want to support max tech check out
that shelf down below or the link in the
video description you definitely won't
be disappointed especially if you like
all the Apple products ok let's go ahead
and open up our new MacBook Pro here
let's start out with geek bench fives
metal score right here we see the 5600 M
I'm going to go ahead and run it now
what's very interesting about this Apple
specific 5600 M is that it is using HP
m2 memory eight gigs of it and that
memory is actually more than twice as
fast as the 5500 M so that is very
impressive now there is also a 5700 M
from AMD
but this 5600 actually has more compute
cores s40 so I don't know what is going
on but Apple has this special edition of
graphics card and I hope it lives up to
its price tag and we have our score it
is 43140 for to put that into
perspective that is more than double the
score of the base 5300 M and that is
just over 50% more performance than the
previous best graphics option what makes
us even more impressive is that all this
performance is coming from the same 50
watt TDP as the 5500 M so they actually
lower the clock speeds but the core
account went from 24 all the way up to
40 so they're making this thing ultra
efficient and we're getting almost the
same amount of performance as the
best-possible
Vega 48 graphics the best option in the
5k iMac and also fairly close to the
Vega 56 that is in the iMac pro so we're
getting desktop level performance in a
laptop before we do some real-world
video editing tests let's run GFX
benches metal test here
and here we have it for ask tech ruins
we got 135 frames per second that
compares to I have 94 the previous best
and 86 for the 5300 M so we didn't have
a big difference between the base and
the high-end before because we went from
20 chorus up to 24 now we have 14 we're
seeing a pretty big difference and as
far as the Manhattan test we went up to
258 point 9 so basically 259 frames per
second once again a pretty big
difference compared to our previous best
graphics cards including the previous
graphics cards Vega 20 that had HBM to
memory now strong our gaming benchmark
this is Unigine heaven with the extreme
preset and here's our score we have
seventy five point seven frames per
second once again using that extreme
preset that is pretty good that's about
50% faster than the previous best 5500 M
even faster than the previous graphics
cards and one interesting thing is you
guys could probably hear the fans right
now but the GPU proximity is showing 73
degrees Celsius for the temperature so
the fans are spinning up but it's
keeping that GPU cool and what I was
very impressed by is this graphics card
in this MacBook Pro is actually beating
out the very best Vega 48 in the 5k iMac
that also uses HP m2 memory and even the
Vega 56 in the iMac Pro also we're doing
this unplugged
we're not plugged into at the wall at
all a lot of gaming laptops they suffer
you know a huge performance decrease if
you unplug it but this graphics card is
optimized at 50 watts and it doesn't
need you to plug it in if you're
interested in more gaming results we're
actually gonna be doing a dedicated
gaming video including installing
windows boot camp we're gonna test that
warzone and some other tests so make
sure you guys click that subscribe
button if you guys want to see that
video but now let's get into video
editing we're gonna start out with Bruce
X over here I'm gonna go ahead and
export this test project that really
pushes the graphics card for rendering
and we have nine
for Bruce X that is fast so that's more
than twice as fast compared to the base
graphics card good amount faster than
the 5500 M as you guys could see and
it's actually closer to the Mac Pro
which takes 6 seconds than it is to the
previous best Mac Pro pro graphics card
so definitely once again that is very
impressive and it actually beats out
both the iMac with the best graphics in
the iMac Pro with the Vega 56 so once
again very impressive for graphics
rendering and video editing and now
let's test out video stabilization I'm
no longer using that 20-second clip I'm
gonna straight for a one-minute clip
because these laptops are getting is so
fast with Final Cut so let's go ahead
and get started here and we have 10
seconds to stabilize this one-minute
clip excellent speed compared to 15
seconds was our previous best and let's
make this a little bit more difficult I
have Canon C 200 raw footage this is a
30 second clip there's a lot more
processing that needs to be done let's
go ahead and start the stabilization
here alright and we have 39 seconds Wow
ok so you guys see the previous ones
right here there's barely any difference
between these different generations and
graphics cards until this new 5600 M
where it is almost twice as fast as the
5500 M that is very impressive and that
shows that we definitely had a graphics
bottleneck because these other machines
have 6 cores or 8 cores all that stuff
but the graphics is holding it back and
all of all while being the same a
wattage very interesting now let's go
ahead and test out an export for an
actual project and now let's go ahead
and do an export test this is my
standard five-minute 4k test I have to
Lutz applied some Corrections and film
grain and I've had it running for a bit
now and I'm seeing something that looks
very interesting so I think that really
sticks out to me it's the graphics card
is only being used at 73% you guys could
see right here our memories not even
maxed out our processor is at 74% now
we're not seeing 100% usage
and the reason is is that the graphics
is not really limitation even with 4k
full resolution with those effects
tacked on it's more than powerful enough
so if you're doing more simple type of
video editing even different titles and
effects this might be kind of overkill
for you guys let's go ahead and see what
time it takes that took three minutes
and three seconds and the previous
versions got three minutes and 21
seconds so a little bit faster but
really not by much so unless you're
gonna be doing a lot more facts or be
doing like 6k or maybe even a K editing
it might be a little bit too much of a
graphics card where you're not gonna
utilize all of it just like the graphics
card I have in my Mac Pro now if you
guys want to see more about video
editing especially this timeline
performance and both Premiere Pro and
DaVinci Resolve and Final Cut as well I
love a link in the video description to
my channel after this video I'm gonna be
testing that out in putting that video
out hopefully tomorrow so you guys go
and subscribe to that as well alright
guys so is the 5600 M graphics card
worth it well it depends first off in
metal it scored more than twice as much
compared to the base graphics card and
is scored a lot better than the
higher-end one so that performance was
great and in gaming it did astonishingly
well not only did it perform really well
it actually beat out the best graphics
card you can get in a 5k iMac and even
our $5,000 iMac Pro it beat that out so
gaming is better on the laptop unplugged
on the go that is very impressive what's
more impressive is it's actually faster
than hooking up in a GPU with a 5700 X
graphics card that gets about 70 FPS
compared to I think we got 77 or so
right so 70 5.7 that's what it was so if
you're thinking about getting a base
MacBook Pro and getting at a GPU that's
gonna cost seven eight hundred bucks you
have to have external display this in
trilha graphics card is gonna perform
better so keep that in mind now as far
as video editing some of those some of
the tests were more than twice as fast
as well so definitely from what we can
see the performance is there it
definitely performs shockingly well for
a 50 watt chip and a big performance
enhancement but the
is this makes 800 bucks it is very
expensive it's not cheap the reason why
is that
HBM to memory is extremely expensive
it's more than twice as fast with eight
gigs that really ups the cost with these
graphics chips on the plus side you can
actually buy the base model in upgrade
to this graphics card where before a
couple years ago for the Vega 20 option
you have to buy the high-end MacBook Pro
to even get the option to spend extra
money so Apple's giving us a little bit
more flexibility for somebody that wants
a game on the side after work is done go
for that six core and then maybe get the
best graphics or even for a video
editing with final cuts these programs
are relying more and more on graphics
now than the CPU so I would say instead
of getting an 8 core with a weak or
graphics card go for the 6 core with
this better one and if you're somebody
just getting into it you might as well
not spend extra money go for something a
little bit less expensive we'll have
links down in the video description
below now we are going to be doing a
full review maybe a week from now after
we've done more testing I'm gonna have a
dedicated video for video editing we're
gonna do a video for gaming so make sure
you guys click that circle above so you
guys can subscribe and we will see you
guys in the next video
[Music]